che capelli di merda che bello fare vino
in cucina mi sento tutto un
cannavacciuolo quando lo faccio bene a
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo lui
ed io sono fra vj ed oggi dopo due
miliardi e mezzo di richieste
ho deciso di fare un video support e
lungo prima di cominciare ragazzi vi
faccio vedere come sono messo perché non
vi ho fatto ancora vedere la mia squadra
quindi vi introduca un attimo collegato
scommesso ti faccio vedere prima il mio
personaggio allora io sono questo mi
chiamo darker lumson nome di merda primo
perché fa vj mia me lo avevano potuto
tutti cioè nel senso non c'era più un
nick name confavi jc tipo fa vj stupra
mia nonna era occupato sono livello 20
quindi ho sbloccato adesso le ultra voi
che si sbloccano al menti sono nella
squadra coraggio quindi la squadra rossa
norme venite a cagare cazzo che non sono
blu e roma gaga the arcani che sono
rosso da quando sono nato naso rosso
razzisti e come ultimo ragazzi sui
capelli più ordinati dei miei nella vita
reale non è quello ci vuole tanto eh
vabbè allora ragazzuoli passiamo la cosa
più importante ora john di clet vicino
cazzo passiamo ragazzi alla cosa più
importante ovvero la squadra di pokémon
allora pokémon attualmente ragazzi la
mia squadra è questa qua in i pokemon
master sono vapore un pin single da
ratifica che uso io per salire di
livello e molto semplice ma anche perché
una tattica che usano quasi tutti ora
esiste in questo gioco bellissimo il
fort un nuovo che sarebbe questo il fort
un nuovo fa guadagnare il doppio dei
punti esperienza per 30 minuti e quando
lo attivo facciamo odio che è spuntato
un bellissimo prix jay bhatt makeba che
bello cos'è il teatro ragazzi guardate
che bel setup che ciò per registrare il
video ma figlio di [ __ ] mi stavo
dicendo dai che due palle fai anche
cagare bella pista va dicendo ragazzi la
tattica che uso per salire di livello e
attivare il fortunoso quindi avere il
doppio dell'esperienza per 30 minuti e
quando lo faccio faccio evolvere
tantissimi pj appunto perché tantissimi
pj perché i pg si trovano con una
facilità estrema
avevo uno sulla videocamera fatti se
vedete cio 218 caramelle pg che non sono
neanche troppissime per far evolvere un
pg ci vogliono 12 caramelle lo vedete
qua sotto
quindi all'incirca posso far evolvere
sui 15 pj più o meno quando fate voi
avere un pokémon
se non sbaglio vita o 500 1000 di
esperienza non mi ricordo tipo 500
se avete fortwo nuovo attivo che al
doppio dell'esperienza venne da mille
quindi ragazzi sefat evolvere 15 frigge
invii da 15.000 di esperienza in poche
parole credo è se non il doppio e non mi
ricordo quindi ragazzi la mia tattica su
poiché non vuoi semplicemente mettere
fortwo nuovo e far evolvere pg come se
non ci fosse un domani che vedrà l'altro
ragazzi il mio spazio dei pokémon sembra
quello di un pescivendolo cazzo di nani
magica o tipo 221 caramelle se li
trasferisco tutti ne avrò tipo 270 cm
almeno 50 magica da trasferire poi mi
mancano ancora 150 fottute caramelle per
quel figlio di [ __ ] di gary dossier
quindi ragazzi queste erano le mie
tattiche di pokemon goccia e alla fine
non sono un fenomeno è quindi se avete
dei consigli datemi pure sicuramente da
questo video avete capito come catturare
un vj cosa molto importante è niente
ragazzi allora passiamo la seconda parte
di questo video ho provato a fare delle
riprese fuori casa e sono uscite delle
cose abbastanza fig e quindi vi lascio
al video bella ragazza ma no ma no ma
sto pagando non nel cesso
grazie ad esso c'è un pj ogni tre
secondi son pg per terra ma possibile
sta roba
peccato un po che stop che sarebbe sto
pezzo di gamba de legn e questo sarebbe
gamba de legn i sei serio c'è un cazzo
di mister mai ho trovato mister mai
veramente aspetta aspetta che lancio non
uscì per uscire dai cazzo l'ho preso
dovrei 9 aveva preso visto ormai un
regalo non ci posso credere ho sempre
sognato di avere un cazzo di mimmo in
casa finalmente sei fermate fermo vieni
guarda la tua adatto a destra volato a
destra
esatto un po più in basso tu sei i teli
e coperte fermo di fermo tantissimo
immobile bravo mica pdf
ecco niente grazie a tecniche
sì certo corri più antico avanti poi
niente ok 6 la perfetto e porti fortuna
ok funziona grazie caro pokemon gomma
trovo solo pokemon da schifo signora in
questo o gu
ma veramente sfruttato un nido queen
capire dove cazzo ma qui non i doc ying
non so quale dei due però mi chiami e
spuntato ciao come state aprire trovato
nido queen da qualche parte cerca i
pokémon vi darei la mano ma in questo
momento ciò non alla camera e l'altra
telefono mi spiegate come questa roba
possa essere anche solo minimamente
fisicamente possibile ma belli dentro il
lago o santo iddio sotto il mio santi
dio santo iddio
ma [ __ ] si finse fortissimo si
vede cioè a 635 zio aspetta che ci
riesco a fra i modelli lo prendo subito
lo prendo uno ci sono è mancato non
l'avrei spettacolo
due le imprese periodo mi guardare
questo posto è uscito perché sei sicuro
che sono figli di qualche scappano e non
è scappato [ __ ] bastarda incredibile
non lo è perché sul no sono storto e mi
è comparso un pokemon ripreso sono lì li
aspetta buono abbiamo 500 se orsono
forte
[Musica]
ma quello è uno storno e niente ragazzi
questo video su poche mongolo che vi ho
fatto vedere più o meno come sto messo
adesso spero che il video vi sia
piaciuto spero di essere stato anche
solo leggermente utile va già bene
almeno sette aggiornati su come sta
messo sul tuo gioco mi sta rubando anche
l'anima cioè che la precedono su un
tracciato momento è un mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook che è il loro canale
che senza vestiti sia 10 diavolo questo
video belle ragazze